ما بقى في اوكرانيا حيث اعلن وزير الدفاع
النرويجيه
ان بلاده ستزود اوكرانيا بوحدتين كاملتين
من منشات منظومه الدفاع الجوي
بالتعاون مع الولايات المتحده وقال بيان
لوزاره الدفاع النرويجيه ان اوكرانيا
بحاجه ماسه للحمايه من الهجمات الصاروخيه
وان النرويج ستقدم المساعده واضافت
الوزاره ان منظومه ناسانز اثبتت فعاليتها
وان اضافه وحدتي اطلاق نار اخريائيين
ستحسنان قدره اوكرانيا على الدفاع عن
مدنها وبنيتها التحتيه الحيويه من الهجمات
الصاروخيه
قد نقلت عن مسؤول كبير بالاتحاد الاوروبي
قوله ان الاتحاد ربما يضخ مبلغ ثلاثه
مليارات ونصف المليار يورو اضافي في
الصندوق المستخدم لشراء الاسلحه لاوكرانيا
وبموجب خطه وضعها مسؤول سياسه الخارجيه
بالاتحاد الاوروبي فان الدول الاعضاء
ستحصل على حوافز ماليه بقيمه مليار يورو
لارسال المزيد من قذائف المدفعيه الى كييف
بينما سيخصص الاتحاد مبلغ مليار يورو اخر
لتمويل المشتريات المشتركه من القذائف
الجديده